welcome to this video playing p ed from
denmark again a cow kong can i play
something else here maybe maybe let's go
for the two nights variation just to to
have some variety always going to age
five
yeah I know that taking and g4s the
prescribed antidote but maybe just just
try to develop him I don't know any
anything theoretically detailed here
anyway hmm
hmm yeah probably like I already has a
quite comfortable game but I need to
post some problems yeah probably g-form
if I don't play something like that it's
it's simple it's just too easy for black
yeah I need to need to ignore the big
coupon just try to play actively may be
here so that on c5 I have night a form
and if it takes well look we want to
resend some night a for now
yeah all this was the idea anyway yes so
he prevented me from castling long the
main point of order system that I'm
quite quite nicely developed maybe I can
post some concrete problems Quincy 3
maybe but the intention to go even
before
yeah well maybe 97 something map but
still p for a for very strange chest but
i need to play with concrete threats
inform intending a five and b5 winning
the Queen this probably is not going to
happen but he's ignoring the idea I it's
not that he's got beehive protected so
it's not winning the Queen but if five
well one not a five if he goes rook c8
queen bee three at the end he needs to
retreat the bishop and this is not a bad
end game I can go to c7 actually wait
wait for a moment if I take one b6 Luke
c3 rock a six no it's not working at all
but queen bee three now if you move the
bishop then be five isn't the strapping
trapping the Queen
be fine his queen is trapped
okay so we need to do something I'm not
threatening to take here yes yes Roxy
form because a one is hanging and on b5
this Bishop f5
ok but Roxy for I can this is the
opportunity actually to Castle I can
castle here
now I'm threatening to take on b6 and
threatening b5
hey this winning know what does strange
game
I have Lewis pieces this is always a
problem but because of this very
concrete play with g4 it's very much
possible that he had some some good move
along the way because it all looks
rather strange my plane but then it
seems to be working winning material
and concrete metas always met are more
important than any abstract evaluation
like loose pieces and glue scale or
whatever if you win you win okay rabbit
it's still not completely completely
trivial maybe queen a grenade for ya I
want to exchange Queens the night is
hanging on d7 so he needs to allow a
queen trade
yeah this looks good simplifying the
position a bit hmm he can take here but
no I officially say wow I'm missing so
many easy moves at the moment
I want to go to see seven check no he's
continuing black resigns no ya won't
Luke be one whatever it's just to look
quite a strange game I don't I don't
really know what's going on it's easily
possible that black is an excellent
champion yeah black computer gives
Blackett package yeah it's a it's a very
loose type of position I just wish
should be saving here that's a good
movie yeah you know sometimes just don't
really consider this is this kind of
move because well you're king and so on
but look at this I mean I have no way to
ever threaten the king and this rook c8
positionally have befallen g4 just full
of holes so this would have refuted my
concept quite quite directly but this is
probably still okay only need to be more
precise here yeah this is really a
blunder allowing me to castle view if
you play it moves like that after b5 you
have this check this is just the the big
big point and this is also if he manages
to just secure the Queen I'm toast
really can ever have a castle I'm full
of just a weaknesses its position and
now I'm winning I'm just winning a
material so I played really badly but he
made this one big mistake that let it
slip it's a kind of reversed roles I am
I have those kind of games very often on
the black side where the other person is
applying for some concrete stuff which
is not really working but failed to
exploit it and now I was playing badly
and he didn't exploit it
but it made for interesting the
interesting game here's just just a
piece for nothing alright thanks for
watching